[Música]
recta final en eeuu yo vaivén estará
este lunes en pensilvania y en ohio
mientras que en medio de una frenética
agenda el presidente de trump visitará
este lunes carolina del norte- wisconsin
michigan y pensilvania el mandatario
atacó nuevamente la modalidad del voto
por correo y negó que planee cantar
victoria prematuramente como se ha
reportado en la prensa estadounidense
brasil superó los 160 mil muertos por
ccoo vil 19 el país es el segundo en el
mundo con más fallecimientos por la
pandemia sólo detrás de eeuu en la
ciudad de sao paulo cientos de
seguidores del presidente ya ir
bolsonaro protestaron contra los planes
del gobierno regional que haría
obligatoria la vacuna china si se prueba
que es segura y efectiva
ascendió a 85 el número de fallecidos
tras el terremoto que golpeó a grecia y
turquía este viernes los equipos de
búsqueda continúan trabajando a
contrarreloj mientras disminuyen las
esperanzas de encontrar sobrevivientes
bajo los escombros
buenos días y bienvenidos a esta emisión
de noticias en france24 soy valentina
torres sánchez gracias por su compañía
iniciamos en eeuu donde los candidatos a
la presidencia entraron en la recta
final de la campaña a las elecciones de
este martes ambos aspirantes buscan
conquistar los últimos apoyos en estados
pendular es el presidente de donald
trump implementó una frenética agenda
entre domingo y lunes ayer visitó cinco
estados y hoy tiene previsto viajar a
otros cuatro al tiempo que volvió a
criticar la supuesta falta de
transparencia de los votos por correo a
sólo un día de los comicios la polémica
se centra en un informe del medio
digital action que indica que el jefe de
estado ya tendría un plan para declarar
su victoria en la noche de este martes
aunque no se conozcan los resultados
finales algo que el mandatario niega su
rival demócrata joe biden llamó a votar
de manera masiva
este fue un reporte falso miraremos qué
pasa creo que es algo terrible cuando se
pueden recolectar votos después de una
lección
creo que es terrible cuando a personas o
estados se les permite tabular votos por
un largo periodo de tiempo después de la
elección
porque eso sólo puede llevar a una cosa
y es algo muy malo
usted sabe a qué me refiero es cierto es
algo muy peligroso y terrible creo que
es terrible cuando no podemos conocer el
resultado de una elección en la misma
noche de la elección en la era de los
computadores esta es la elección más
importante de nuestras vidas estamos en
un punto de inflexión tenemos que votar
como nunca lo hemos hecho antes cada día
es un nuevo recordatorio de todo lo que
está en juego y hasta dónde llegará el
otro partido para impedir el voto
especialmente aquí en filadelfia el
presidente está aterrado por lo que
pasará en pensilvania él sabe que si la
gente de pensilvania vota él no tiene
ninguna oportunidad
y cuando faltan menos de 24 horas para
que inicie esta decisiva jornada
electoral establecemos comunicación con
antonella martín ella es analista
política y directora del center for
latino américa en washington dc señora
mari martin bienvenida a france 24
estamos en la recta final de los
comicios y las polémicas no cesan
hablemos del reporte de este reporte de
la revista action según el cual el
presidente de trump estaría ya listo
para cantar victoria en la noche del
martes el lo niega sin embargo es una
preocupación ya que el mandatario ha
hablado de fraude desde hace meses qué
pasa si en efecto trump se declara
ganador antes de tiempo que seguiría
después
buenos dias valentinas bueno yo creo que
además de todos estos análisis y
obviamente encuestas que se están
haciendo hemos visto muchos números a lo
largo de estos días ahora más allá de
esto hay un número bastante llamativo y
que presenta por supuesto lo opuesto
al día de hoy sabemos más allá de todo
que más de 93 millones de personas ya
emitieron su voto anticipado para estas
elecciones en eeuu un número muy elevado
equivale prácticamente al 67 por ciento
de la participación total que vimos en
las elecciones del año 2016 y hay un
fuerte interés por por los comicios y
esto quedando solamente no en ahora no a
las elecciones según las encuestas ahora
de que todo esto suceda yo bailé en
lideraría con bastante claridad las
proyecciones de intención de voto en una
buena cantidad de estados a lo largo del
país 52 por ciento de las personas que
irían a votar o que ya lo hicieron
anticipadamente dice que lo hará por
wyler no frente a un 43 por ciento que
se inclina por por donald trump
y yo creo que en esto en términos de
encuestas y como bien decía sabemos que
vayan se muestra la delantera de donald
trump era al menos en cuatro estados
decisivos todos ellos en pensilvania
arizona florida y wisconsin throne ganó
en las elecciones de 2016 no de todas
maneras se llama regularmente a la
cautela en estos términos yo creo que
eso es algo que también debería estar
haciendo al presidente donald trump y
muchos de estos estudios que analizamos
porque recordemos que a veces las
encuestas y los números no nos dicen
verdaderamente lo que lo que va a
suceder no nos olvidemos que en eeuu no
hay una elección sino 51 elecciones no
se eligen por iu a través de colegios
electorales entonces hay que esperar
hasta último momento señora martín vemos
a los candidatos enfocados en los
estados pendulares en este último día de
campaña pero de todos ellos hablemos de
pensilvania por qué es tan importante y
por qué hay temores ante la muy posible
demora de los conteos de los votos por
correo en este estado
bueno en esto yo creo que tenemos que
tener muy en cuenta como bien decíamos
recién cuáles son los estados pendulares
y vuelvo a insistir en el modo que tiene
el modo de sistema este electoral de los
de los eeuu y esto nos va a llevar a por
qué es tan importante y por qué hay
estados que son pendulares y que son
fundamentales no hay que muestran
digamos una trayectoria
a lo largo de la historia de las
presidencias de eeuu y en las victorias
que han sido cruciales a la hora de
definir una elección ahora volvemos
estos datos y como bien decíamos recién
datos que nos dicen poco acerca de cómo
realmente está la carrera presidencial
se puede ir dando no nos olvidemos que
se pueden sacar más votos y a la vez se
pueden perder las elecciones como le
sucedió a hillary clinton en el que
digamos en el voto popular se impuso por
más de 48 por ciento contra 46 pero en
el colegio electoral digamos terminó
perdiendo por 304 a 227 no entonces yo
creo que estos son los detalles que
tenemos que tener en cuenta y cuáles son
los estados
pendular es que van a marcar
precisamente que nos marcan hoy la
intención de voto en los eeuu sí señor
muchas gracias ya es antonella martí a
analista política gracias por su
análisis ya veremos qué ocurre mañana en
estas elecciones calificadas como las
más importantes en la historia reciente
de eeuu
vamos ahora a américa latina
puntualmente a brasil que superó las 160
mil muertes por kobe 19 tras registrar
190 fallecimientos en las últimas 24
horas con lo que se ratifica como el
segundo país del mundo con más pérdidas
debidas por la pandemia sólo por detrás
de eeuu la nación suramericana también
registró 10 mil 100 casos en la última
jornada lo que eleva el total a más de 5
millones 545 mil en la ciudad de sao
paulo cientos de seguidores del
presidente ya ir bolsonaro protestaron
contra el plan del gobierno regional que
aseguró que la vacuna china coronaba que
sería hoy sería obligatoria si se prueba
su efectividad y seguridad
estamos en contra el autoritario
embajador chino yo autor ya el ahora
quiere imponer una vacunación
obligatoria en contra de nuestra
voluntad esto no existe en ningún lugar
del mundo ni siquiera en china esta
vacuna es obligatoria para la gente el
director de la ms ha declarado que darle
la vacuna a la gente de manera
autoritaria no funciona esto no puede
ocurrir continuamos en colombia donde
este domingo se registraron
multitudinarias marchas de ex
integrantes de la desmovilizada
guerrilla de las farc para reclamar al
gobierno que cumpla a cabalidad con el
acuerdo de paz y se acaben los
asesinatos de ex combatientes desde la
firma del pacto en 2016 se han
registrado la muerte violenta de 236 de
ellos los manifestantes estarán en
bogotá la capital colombiana hasta el
jueves donde continuarán pidiendo el fin
de la violencia
pero lo que pretendemos es sensibilizar
a la sociedad colombiana queremos
sensibilizar a este país y por supuesto
llamar también la atención del gobierno
nacional y del estado porque hasta el
día de hoy han sido asesinados 236
guerrilleros y escondieran firmantes del
acuerdo de paz no podemos repetir la
historia el destino de este país no
puede seguir siendo un conflicto armado
y eterno y por eso queremos que la
sociedad colombiana entienda que no se
trata simplemente de salvar la vida de
quienes dejamos las armas pensando en el
cumplimiento de la palabra del estado
sino en la necesidad de construir un
país más justo democrático y eso tiene
que ver con la garantía primero que todo
del derecho a la vida de todos los
colombianos cambiamos de continente
vamos a europa porque se elevó a 85 el
número de personas que perdieron la vida
tras el terremoto que sacudió el mar
egeo el viernes dos de las víctimas en
grecia y 83 en turquía donde avanzan las
labores de rescate a contrarreloj los
equipos de búsqueda que continúan
trabajando en ocho edificios de la
ciudad turca
esmirna lograron rescatar a una niña de
tres años y a un adolescente de 14 de
entre los escombros de dos edificios
colapsados informe de aurora valle
más de 65 horas después del desastre los
esfuerzos de rescate siguen cosechando
éxitos en turquía
en esmirna esta niña de 3 años fue
rescatada de entre los escombros que
dejó el terremoto del mar egeo sin
embargo en irak y otro sector duramente
golpeado la esperanza de hallar
supervivientes se desvanece casi 6000
rescatistas han estado trabajando día y
noche a veces pidiendo silencio para
poder escuchar cualquier llamado de
auxilio las primeras 72 horas después
del terremoto son muy importantes así
que planeamos trabajar hasta ese momento
después de eso otras personas vendrán a
reemplazarlos porque la posibilidad de
encontrar sobrevivientes será pequeña
después de 72 horas muchos residentes ya
pasaron tres noches al aire libre por
miedo a las réplicas para acomodarlos
las autoridades han suministrado más de
3500 tiendas de campaña
debido al shock psicológico del
terremoto pasamos la mitad de la noche
durmiendo y la otra mitad despiertos por
las réplicas hoy hemos distribuido 600
sopas 600 panes y 800 yogures nuestro
papel es hacer que las víctimas sientan
que estamos de su lado el terremoto se
produce el viernes por la tarde en el
mar egeo al suroeste de esmirna la
tercera mayor ciudad de turquía su poder
fue tal que se sintió hasta estambul y
atenas en la isla griega de samos donde
murieron dos adolescentes las
situaciones extremadamente difíciles
según las autoridades al menos 16
personas han perdido la vida tres
permanecen desaparecidas y miles de
viviendas sufrieron daños mayores tras
el paso del tifón con y por filipinas
el fenómeno se dirige hacia vietnam con
vientos de hasta 75 kilómetros por hora
y de acuerdo con las autoridades podría
fortalecerse en su recorrido según los
meteorólogos goni es el tifón más fuerte
del año
pasamos al norte de siria una región
devastada por la guerra en la que viven
cerca de 1.5 millones de personas en
campamentos de refugiados abarrotados de
gente casi siempre sin servicio de agua
y en condiciones precarias
el miedo de estas personas se
intensifica debido a la propagación del
cob y 19 en la nación del medio oriente
veamos más detalles en el siguiente
informe
tantas carpas en el horizonte como el
ojo puede ver en este campamento de
refugiados provisional en la aldea de
cada provincia y dilip a sanz de 41 años
habita este pequeño refugio de concreto
junto con sus seis hijos él y su familia
ahora también tienen que preocuparse por
el coronavirus que vivimos en un
campamento todos abarrotados si alguien
habla con su familia todos los vecinos
pueden escuchar a uno de mis familiares
de contagio de kobe 19 hace un tiempo y
yo estoy muy asustado porque tengo una
enfermedad preexistente
esta historia se repite en otros
refugios del campamento aquí tomar una
ducha o incluso lavarse las manos es un
lujo y el distanciamiento social es
imposible de acuerdo con naciones unidas
el número de casos de kobe 19 en el
nororiente de siria es seis veces mayor
de lo que era hace un mes el instituto
médico de it le respondió a la pandemia
de coronavirus en los campamentos del
norte de varias formas trabajando en
campañas de concientización en
cooperación con varias organizaciones
disponiendo de cuatro líneas de atención
para responder a las inquietudes de los
ciudadanos y trabajando para disponer de
ambulancias y centros de 40 en after
market sin embargo esto está lejos de
ser suficiente para disminuir la curva
de contagios en síria en estos
campamentos abarrotados de gente es más
probable que la propagación del virus
sea más rápida que en otros países aquí
los trabajadores de la salud están en
alerta ante una potencial catástrofe
sanitaria
y finalizamos en perú porque con una
tradicional ceremonia de agradecimiento
machu picchu reabrió sus puertas al
público este patrimonio mundial de la
unesco tuvo que cerrar durante meses
debido a las restricciones por la
pandemia de kobe 19 ahora los turistas
podrán visitar el lugar con medidas de
seguridad que incluyen un máximo de 675
personas por día y distanciamiento
social
a ustedes gracias continúen con más en
france 24
[Música]